[Music]
laughs
excitement distress beacon oh yeah baby
you're excited about that
i'm confused as to how at this point
morty is surprised by anything that rick
says or does
the first rule of space travel kids is
always check out distress beacons
oof rick is using an outdated space
travel rule book the most important rule
of space travel is to wear your seat
belt
seems like something terrible happened
here really where'd you get that idea
summer was it the ship in disarray no
signs of life or maybe the [ __ ]
distress beacon that brought you here
summer makes worse observations than
forced whitaker and species oh yeah if
you find a room full of eggs
don't shy away from it give one of them
a shake so does this mean that
xenomorphs exist in this universe
which would also mean the regular space
exploration is something that exists on
earth and rick shouldn't be getting away
with as much as he does
also does no one find it weird that when
they watch ghostbusters or gorillas in
the mist that the lead actress looks
straight up like ellen ripley
oh hey you're alive thank god false
optimism
then how do you know it didn't get on
the ship with you those two ding dongs
seem pretty calm about the whole thing
which poses the question why did they
wait till now to attack the rest of the
crew
even if unity was hoping someone would
show up from the distress signal they
could also take over that still doesn't
explain
why these two didn't attack after the
beacon was transmitted
why screech make the attack incredibly
obvious there's got to be a better way
for a brilliant entity to expertly and
covertly convert everyone into
well everyone whoever grows here must
love to be saturated in water but only
in one tiny place on the whole lawn i'm
trying to find
our weed whacker jerry's dumb you know
that
i know that but i can't help but sin
that he's looking for a long lawn tool
on a shelf
where no one would ever store a weed
whacker your father put a hatch in my
garage which means now you have even
more storage space under the garage
and probably added ten to twenty
thousand dollars to the value of the
house jerry never sees the glass half
full
he's toe up from the flow up this is
season two and they still haven't
managed to move
this plug down here to one of the
obvious three open ports
i hate you all world peace achieved nice
little weird to publish a paper about it
for yourself i think at this point we
can agree that rick would be the
employee of the month that tv sends
when we met i was a young hive mind
people who talk to you while walking
away
i suppose a peaceful utopia needs a
police force for something
mount rushmore this quickly show really
puts the rush into rushmore huh
well this explains the six thousand
dollar electric bill
wait what was the previous explanation
that sounds far more exciting than this
jerry beth bickering b
story wake up people you have to fight
it
you're under the spell of an evil
monster i can hear you
every four years in the united states of
america wake up you have to have some
individuality left in there
pep talks around the writing table
during cinemas and staff meetings this
woman was a drug addict on the verge of
suicide
now she's a marine biologist which isn't
impressive when you consider that
everyone on the planet is also a marine
biologist thanks to the hive mind i have
transformed life here into a paradise
prostitutes are now scientists
insinuating that sex workers cannot
also be scientists in a perfect world
are they all the same organism is the
mind telling them to puke unity can read
their minds improve them with education
link everyone together
and relieve her drug binge through
individuals how does this even work
i can let go can you also teleport
people because in exactly four seconds
the city is destroyed in all the people
are somehow way over here
rick can hear this from far away inside
a building and with loud techno music
playing
and i'll be damned if that ripple nipple
bitch's race is superior
those are some very impressive conical
nipples attached to that [ __ ] nibbles
that were clearly not present beneath
that shirt just a moment ago
hey these two freaks have no race
speaking of freaks what's going on with
this crowd of totally still people back
here
are they unity controlled just standing
by all hands on hips angry looking
are they rioters frozen in terror or is
this lazy animation
you want to go upstairs and cut carrots
and watch a lifetime original
above a alien dungeon surprisingly mommy
may i please have an alien dungeon
proved to be a very uplifting piece of
filmmaking
especially for a lifetime movie i once
saw him briefly forget the word for
humans
this sets up a joke later in the episode
but it's really not that big of a deal
to forget a word every now and again
our minds calculate thousands of
decisions a day so what if we forget a
word
like right now i'm having trouble
remembering the word for that thing
that's like
soft but then it gets hard you know you
put it in holes and cracks
it's really good in places that are wet
oh yeah yeah [ __ ]
you and unity are like like leggings and
mid-calf boots
you think you're great together but
you're just bringing out the worst in
each other
that's fashionist if blim blam could rip
the chains off this whole time then why
was he still locked up
i'd laugh but i'm biologically incapable
but somehow capable of communicating
clear words and dynamically expressive
versions of just not able to
ha ha is there a slow setting
best door ever sarcastic aliens not
named alf
unity community rick forgive me for
doing this in notes
breaking up with someone through a
letter also reading
no more alien prisoners but aliens
suspended in some sort of liquid chamber
are okay
is anyone going to address these
[Music]
emotionally relevant song sincerely
plays at the end of a rick and morty
episode while also making fun of
emotionally relevant songs that play at
the end of tv shows
cliche
she touched my peppy steve
that's what we're gonna find out balloon
summer balloon
morty i don't like chicken and i hate
clowns
under your ships